me
guys
well I started with English because
I'm used to English but
welcome to our first
question and answer session in Spanish that's
the first time we've done it in Spanish
I'm doing it in Spanish welcome
everyone and
I'll start right away because we have  more or
less an hour
70 minutes let's say more or less and I am going to
read the questions that they have asked me they have asked me
a lot of questions and I am going to
do a little I am going to answer a few
questions here on this sheet that I have and
your questions  in the chat it seems a
bit of both of the two things
but it can be a bit complicated
because normally with the chat you have a
lot of very interesting questions
another thing I wanted to tell you and if you see
door and kevin are the two moderators
who are here in the chat so we are here
and we can start
we start with the first question I'm
fine thanks kuwait he asks me hello
crazy how are you very well
hello everyone I see that here  i have my dad
too yours
the chat let's see that I have a lot
of things to the right and to the left
i
hello everyone again we start
then
again what we are going to do is I am going to
read the questions that they have asked me
directly to  through the google form and
then you can take a look at the chat and
I'm going to answer your wonderful
questions I'm sure you'll have
a lot of very interesting questions
so then
we'll start if I had to give advice
to a child knowing that this one is
going  what would this be next? a question
that does not necessarily have to do
with language learning but rather an
almost philosophical question.
One thing that my
parents and especially my grandmother have left me is
intellectual curiosity. She is motivated by the
curiosity to know new things. I
learn languages to get to know the world.  I
know better to get to know the world better
to get to know myself
better and that's why I think it's super
important to
keep a certain type of intellectual curiosity
and not just not just
intellectual in life in general this
is the advice I would give to a child who
it starts with life
and someone tells me can you speak in
English please this is a
question and answer session in Spanish and
then unfortunately I am going to speak
unfortunately and fortunately for
you I am going to speak only in
Spanish and I am going to answer only
questions  in spanish
later another question hello luca when and
how did you start to catch your
attention in spanish or do you speak
survivors of the light of this mexico
thank you very much
I started with this course that I have here I
don't know if you can see them and it's called the
Spanish or see you  spanish for you is a
course by d agostini i think the
spaniards also know that it is a course
by agustin and why he went there
too and called me  attention the truth
is that I started with him with German in
1996 and then I realized that there was
the same identical course in Spanish and well
I said to myself what a man there is a course
in the same course in Spanish I'm going to
do it so I started with  Spanish and
it would also be good curiosity to know
how this language works
and then I started and here we are I am going to
read the third question then I am going to
read a couple of questions that you have in
the chat that you already have a lot of
questions
a few days ago I knew that you  and your team
are working on a new course
focused on intermediate students and
tools we will find in this this
new this new course
I don't know if it's true or what good you can
share the link to the
sales page of this of this course well
we have a live course  we are
doing it now but the sales are
closed but and already there
you can have all the information you
need to see what it is about it is a
course for intermediate students  in
which we give the let's say we seek the
mainz & the mentality also the
tools to get
to speak a language fluently any
language because it is a linguistic engineering course
as I like to call it
and we are going to publish the
course not in  I live a course that is called
evergreen in English we are going to publish it
probably in March and April I am
super excited because it is
a lot to share with you how
learning languages is one of the great
st passions and that is why I am sorry if I can
not help you  when to share all
all the information because unfortunately
all the details because
unfortunately we don't have the time
here but already as I told you we have
a sales page with all the
information and what else
michael schulz luca i'm one of your
vdv students dt is the translation
bidirectional value action on
translation in English and I wanted to
ask you how you managed to master
Spanish Spanish phonetics as well  it is one
of the questions that they ask me from
time to time very often in fact
to speak a language well to speak
a language with a good accent with good
pronunciation I think that more than the
deliberate instructions that they give you
at school the most  The important thing is to
create an identity in your target language. I
wanted to sound like a Spaniard. I wanted to be a
Spaniard. I think that is the most
important thing when learning a
language with a good accent and good
pronunciation. It is something psychological
first and foremost and then  Of course,
yes, if you really want to speak
like a native, then you pay attention to all
the details of phonetics. I
work subconsciously, let's say with
phonetics, and deliberately, in the
sense that first of all I like it.
I would like to sound like a native.
part of this tribe not of another tribe there is
a linguist that I don't know if you know
him and you know him his name is steven kasher who
is a crack that is a crack that in
general s  he talks about linguistics is one
of the things he says I don't know if you
can openly share this link there is
an academic paper that is free that
you can't download without
problems in pdf called sectur
on accent here that is to say in  that they did something like that to him
and he talks about the fact
that most adults think
they can't pronounce things well
that they can't pronounce
foreign languages well and the truth is that they can y
s they can it's that they just have
block so it's  a psychological block
because speaking a
foreign language is a bit like belonging
to another tribe in the sense that for
example you belong to your human tribe
in the sense that you speak in a certain
way and then speak a
foreign language then in another way for
you  brain is a bit strange and you
also find resistance I'll tell you I'll tell
you something that happened to me at school
when I was 13 years old more or less I had
started with English and I had  to a
private teacher who helped me a lot
with pronunciation with the language
in general and then I started to speak and
when I spoke at school, not in
English class, people laughed a little,
this one speaks with a girl, she produces those
sounds like a  American and then I
felt like people made fun
of me a little bit I didn't care in Spain
I think they say I suck a foot that I
like an expression I love it invents
it uses it very often
and I didn't care I didn't care that
people make fun of me the truth is that I
wanted to be I wanted to be an American not
only did I want to sound like an American but
I wanted to be an American and that has
made a huge difference when
it comes to learning to speak with a
good pronunciation or with a
almost native pronunciation let's say
let's see if you have other questions I
think so
cristian le goff as an instructor or the
order of the languages the order of the langu
ges he learned how would he start with languages m
re than  difficult like Chinese
Arabic I am 25 years old so I have a lot of
time I want to learn 10 languages
nteresting question I do not have a no
rder in the sense that I have learn
d languages when I wanted to learn I know I le
rned English because I wanted to learn Engli
h I learned the  French
because at first it was one of the things
in one of the languages that I had to learn
at school and then I learn
d German because a course like this had come out and t
en Spanish and then due t
various life
ircumstances I decided to learn other
languages one at a time and I didn't care
bout the level the difficulty of the langu
ge but the desire to speak and use t
is language and connect with the peopl
and the people who speak this langu
ge because it was let's say a desire that I had a
ex
mple is to learn Dutch  the
fifth language i learned is dutch
and i learned it because i had fallen
in love with a dutch girl and this is one of
the reasons why  I started them with him
Hernández who didn't speak much English and
that's why I started this one I started to learn
Dutch after two months I had already
written a letter and then I wrote it
well
in Holland so I don't think
Cristian that you would have to think in
terms  from I'm going to learn 10 languages 15 web l
nguages learn them first the first one is easy the
it's difficult you have to learn the l
nguages you want to learn it's not im
ortant what the language is or th
difficulty of the language if you want to learn
a language you're going to learn it it doesn
t depend on the  difficulty becau
if you fall in love with a language later,
despite the difficulties you may
have, you will achieve it without a doubt
let's see here jose I'm going to
answer two more questions and then you can see
I'm going to take a look at the questions
here to the list of questions I am going to
try to answer everyone it is going to
be a bit complicated but we are going to
try it
we are going to see
greetings from Colombia william thank you
luís  ngel ramírez angel asks me what
do you think about comprehensible input
do you think people should have
prior knowledge to make use of
that
technique comprehensible input is an idea of
on target on crash on the crack
that I was talking about earlier and to expla
n what  what if it is simply a
theory according to which to learn a
language to acquire a language you
need to expose yourself to the ani on the line you
need to listen to me you need to read the
input that is things texts listen to
podcasts that are understandable and
interesting and I
totally agree with  he in the sense that
to learn a language you have to
start with input that is understandable
normally starts for example with
courses like that a thousand and to create let's say
a solid base a solid understanding
of the linguistic
grammatical
morphological structures of a language and then I
develop  good language with others with
other content with podcast with videos
then use  he made a material
into beginner material like this and then he
created my own material that is
understandable and interesting to me i
think he wood is the basis of everything
you should always use
understandable input so i agree with
one with stephen carr to be and you dont
need  no prior knowledge
you just have to use resources
that now there are a lot a lot
of resources that you can use
that you can use you can find the
internet you can find
everywhere so if you use
incomprehensible and what interests you is that
you are interested in it being interesting no  you are
going to have a great time as they say in madrid
maría inés mu denise karbon hi luca
how long will it take to be fluent in
english and speak a million fluently if
you want to speak fluently happened
when it depends on your definition of
fluency no this is the first  what it
means to speak fluently first of
all for me to speak fluently
means you understand the  others you
understand the people with whom
you communicate and then
you can communicate you can speak in this
language and you don't necessarily have to
be perfect a lot of people think that
their child speaks perfect or not
perfectly or you don't speak it that it's not
like that it's not a  barrier that you overcome and that
depends on you how long it takes to
learn a language depends on you depends
on what you do depends on how much time
you want to spend on the language depends on
how you do it because the number of hours
the number of hours you invest in
learning a  language is just one of
several factors that impact your let's say
your language learning so I
can't give you a
precise let's say detailed answer to this
question because speaking fluently
depends on a lot of factors I
would say in general that if you put  yes,
if you put in at least a couple of
hours each day and you do it during and you
do it well, I mean,
you know how to do it, I think
that in English  It's especially for
Spanish-speaking people, let's say, I would say
a year and a half, two years, it also depends
on other things, such as if you already speak other
languages, what knowledge you have about
learning languages, but I would say more or
less between 1 and 2 years and it depends on what
what do you do
and I'm going to answer a couple of questions
here and then I'll go back to the chat
let's see for people who
want to reach a near native level in
a language when you decide to start a
new language and put aside
the one you've been  learning is to say
when you decide that your stage of learning
a language has come to an end even though
it never really ends
well in general I have this rule I
don't know if you know what is called
lower newt with out franz ferdinand
widgets that in Spanish that what
the one pointed out here is called the common
european framework of reference for languages
ou can find, for example, on wikip
dia and according to the definitions provided b2 fo
me means speak
ng  fluently and I usually
learn a language in an active way, let's say
actively, that is, I sit there
and spend an hour doing things
actively for a couple of years a
little less depends on the
linguistic distance between my language my
target language and my language  of destination
sorry sorry and language in my target language
and my mother tongue and if the language is
relatively easy for me like
Italian Spanish for example it took a
year a little less and once I have
reached a level where I can
communicate with others  according to the
definition that I have given before that I
tried before and I speak fluently
let's say I switch to another language normally
I speak learn one language at a time and
then I continue to the next language let's
see another question here and then I return
to the chat
hello I am a Spanish whip speaker
i have a c1 in english and i learned
portuguese in a year using this way he
reads me following your advice he can
listen and read this language well i
would like to learn italian i g  I would like to
learn Italian do you think I can
learn Italian in a year dedicating
30 to 40 minutes a day to it using a thousand
youtube etc. thank you very much well
now to answer your question what
I was saying before is that it depends
on a lot of factors I would say that
with 30  40 minutes if you, if your mother
tongue is Spanish, learning Italian
is clearly not going to be very complicated
if you want, let's say, to reach
a level of farting, it depends on what you
do, if you spend 30 and 40 minutes, it
is possible that you will reach a
good level  level b1 b2 i am not sure with 30
40 minutes a day even though
italian and spanish are very very
similar if you spend for example you invest
two hours a day so in a
year you could save a video the spanish
forgives the italian  fluently so
then what else are we going to see
I'm going to answer a couple of questions here
and
we're going to see ops is that the chat is
that you have a lot of questions it's
quite complicated let's go  let's look
up
andrei says hello luca i don't speak spanish
i'm learning it but if you can
understand it i'll see this string
thanks andreina the important thing is to
understand later you have time to
develop your speech
let's see here
juan torrés greetings greetings from
colombia i have a  problem I have already
learned English but at the beginning
passively listening to music I can't
do it again with German I don't know how to
learn from scratch help me
the problem is that German is a little
more complicated with English with
English and certain languages you can
listen to music or simply
listen to others and you can learn
more easily than in languages that are a littl
more complicated so I think that
n your case and in general if you are learn
ng it does not lead like German and Greek
or Russian that is  a language is a
little more complicated it would be easier
for me to
find books like that they are for
example books like that a thousand are books
that is with or  ne or ones I don't know if so you
can really leave a link
they are books that as I was
saying before have
understandable and quite interesting content that
you can use to create a base and
with this base later you can start
listening to material that is  like I don't know how to
listen to music, songs and other things
but if you don't have a base and you
don't understand the fundamental mechanisms
of a language and it's going to be a bit complicated to
learn a language from scratch in this
way, especially if the language is a
language with a German is  Quite
different from Spanish, English is a
little more similar in terms of syntax and other
things, so my advice is simply
to use a book to start, three
months, four months, you put yourself there,
I'm there for an hour, two hours a day,
you have a solid base and then you can
do  what you are doing and it will
be much easier for you
lorena what would you recommend to start with
languages from scratch what would be the first
steps to  don't get overwhelmed she wants to
start learning Serbian and it would be the
first language I learn on my own
lorena too I'm going to start Serbian
century we're going to start together on
January 3rd I'm going to start Serbian and I to
learn Serbian in general normally
as I answered before to  the question
that I just answered
is about taking a course
like a thousand or like pop one on one the
problem the problem of the Serbian is that
there are no courses in Croatian there are courses in
Croatian for example the patois no one
also in a  simile so there is a
particular course seriously then I'm going to
let you leave a comment
once we've finished this and it's going
to leave you a couple of resources that I would
use for Serbian but in
general advice for everyone if
you want to start a  language from scratch what
you have to do is find a
resource that allows you to create a
solid base and that is an input that is
interesting and understandable so milk is
one of the resources but not only  it
is not the only resource
later we are going to see here a couple of other
questions
we are going to see
leonel or leonel nose leonel or the crazy one I
follow you from your beginnings back in 2008 when
it is 13 years
hello luca I follow you from your beginnings
I am very happy in  your progress
thank you very much no in which was the language
that was most difficult for you to learn and because
as you overcome texts you overcome those
obstacles
the most difficult me the two most diffi
ult languages were and are in Japanese from one side an
Romanian from another [ __ ]
nese  because let's say my way of learning it
did not remember I did not remember very well with
the structure of Japanese sentences and
I made a couple of
fatal mistakes I would say in the beginning to
learn Japanese I have all the resources here
you can't see them like that in the corner
then  It was very difficult for me
because of the syntax because in Japanese you
say things backwards almost not the subject the
verb and the object you have to
completely change the order and the in the other
language
so the  Japanese is objectively
difficult for an Italian and for
speakers of European languages that have a tot
lly different structure a diffe
ent mentality while Roman
an was very difficult for me not because it was diffi
ult in itself but because I did n
t have
eople with whom  which to speak the
language so I lost a bit of
motivation I think that when you
learn a language you have to consider
why you are learning this language
exploited for your work for your life
because you have fallen in love with another person it
is important to understand  why joel
because i didn't know how to learn romanian i
just wanted to tell the truth
i just wanted to add another
language thinking it's easy it's not human it's
very similar to italian or adding
it wasn't very difficult because in the
end i wasn't motivated so a
language  may be difficult for objective reasons such
as the fact that it is
objectively difficult to instantiate  let's tell
you about your mother tongue or about
the languages you already speak and it can be diffi
ult for other reasons such as the fact of be
ng but for l
ck of motivation or other facto
s another question and then we will retur
to the sheet here that  we still have
40 minutes more or less and I
am delighted god and aunts people to
talk to you but
unfortunately we have a limit of
an hour or an hour and maybe an hour and
ten minutes
flury 07 says to dedicate about 30 minutes
every day very  good advice if you want to
learn a language one of the most
important things is to learn every day
sometimes it's difficult because well life
is life and sometimes things happen but if
you can dedicate at least 30 minutes and it's
not necessarily 30 minutes where
you have  you have to sit down and you have to be
there sweating you can quietly
listen to a podcast or other
easier things listening to a song
is contact with the language and you
your brain
your brain  he is very happy about that
because you are telling him you are
sending him a message saying this is
something important it is an
important activity and subconsciously you are going
to learn more and more
samuel I love your videos you give me
motivation thank you very much samuel
greetings from jujuy I don't know if  it's
pronounced jujuy argentina I've never
heard I've heard this this name
let's see I'm reading it on the sat
up so I already know I'm going to
read it another one the other questions you've already asked
me if you want to leave
questions here then you can read them
greetings from Colombia let's go  let's see here
I lost the chat a bit
jesus happy what levels what levels of
the common framework of languages cfr would you say you have
ach of the languages is a bit long to
answer answer this
question in detail let'
say that there are six and six languages a
art from italian  what do I speak I
would say well I communicate well at least
one b2 depends on me I don't really like
the labels we use in this way  arch
of what is called here common
European framework of reference for languages
ey are labels that serve us a bit a
references but the truth is that
ometimes they do not make sense I wou
d say that I speak well that is to say that I defen
myself let's say in several langu
ges so  least there is one, let's say six or seven that
I speak every week and not every
day Spanish is one of those languages
lian what mother tongue in En
lish I always do I
on't know I've been learning English for 30 years and I
think I have a level  high in
English in Spanish in German than more
English French because I lived in France-
I had a French girlfriend I
attended a school in France- of
interpreters French is almost a
second language for me Spanish because
I don't speak every day because my colleague
with me  colleague berta with my friends and
spanish teachers too so i
have the privilege and opportunity to
speak spanish almost every day and
this clearly helps and after that more
e  I don't speak German well I started with this
wonderful course there that
I have somewhere and 25 years ago he spoke a
lot I did this school in
France also with German as one
of the languages I spoke so I speak these four
anguages in Russian  I speak it
well Polish is another Polish Russian language
that I speak very often almost
every day so I would say those six those
six languages are the most Itali
n languages with which yes through
playing is I had a lot of experience
ith  people
visiting the country living depends on
France and well France in
Spain too so I have a lot of
experience that's why I would say that they are
languages that he speaks at a very high level and then
e speaks other languages well like Dutch and S
edish I don't speak Dutch and Swedish ver
I often lived with a
Dutch girl that's why I speak it every
day I speak it well I would say between p2
and c1 so at a fairly high level
of Dutch the Swedish I think I speak it
bi  in but I don't speak it very often
Portuguese is very similar to Spanish
sometimes I speak Portuñol but it is very
similar to Spanish so in the end it
is not a difficult language to learn we are going to
answer a couple of questions here on the
Italian sheet and podcast  thank you place is
a crack we know each other you are a crack
also Italian podcast that happened to follow
to prepare each of the four
parts of the c2 exam in exchange for you and
today this is a complicated question I
prepare many of my students
in private classes for  those courses
for this type of exams let's say that
I would advise isles here
we are going to see advice this is the advantage
of being here right next to the bookstore
it is called isles I advise you this if
you want to prepare for an exam I
advise you to buy books like this in
particular this is amazing why you are
going to do is you are going to follow this this
book you are going to do everything and you are
prepared for the exam so
let's say this exam is c  Like the air you
need to prepare yourself even the
natives find it difficult because you have to
prepare specifically for this for
this exam but if you not only have to
read this book but you have to use
this book do all of you and then
to know that you are going to have a good time
Saturday ming works for language learning
I don't know if you know Saturday men
Saturday bing is a technique like I don't
know for example you listen to a podcast and the
turkey the turkey speaks and you continue to say more
and repeat live what is what they
are  saying
and the truth is that it works to
develop a good articulation
of sounds but it depends on how you
do it so if you want to do it if you
feel like it and you like it because I
don't say I do something a little different
that now I don't have time to
explain it but I  I think that Saturday
ming is always an activity that if
you like,
let's say, you
adapt the technique to what you like to do
because it's very good for  articulation
let's say of the sounds to produce the
sounds for your pronunciation in general
and
how to transform passive vocabulary
into active but not the easiest thing is
speaking speaking and revising I have
a system of notebooks I have those
little notebooks that are out there
unfortunately they are  far
but let's say that I write down words and
phrases especially fragments of phrases
that interest me and then he reviewed them a
couple of minutes each day this to
review them in general to activate your
vocabulary the easiest thing is to talk
to people you can create a bridge
between input  output I will give you an example
suppose that for example you have
not a teacher of you are learning
English or you are learning French and
you have a teacher or tandem or a friend
or a friend with whom
you can speak their target language later if
you listen to a podcast you  you can write down
phrases and fragments that interest you and
then if these fragments are
relevant and important  For you, you can
use them to communicate with your
friend and tell her to make a summary of
a podcast or an article, a book that
you have read, and this is a very
effective and very fun way to activate your
vocabulary
and
how you study the languages that you learn on a daily
basis.  learning routine is another
question that is a bit complicated to
answer in two minutes we have a
lot of questions but what I am telling you
is what I want to tell you to do it
to put it succinctly is to
learn every day for at least 30
minutes and listening  and reading things that
interest you and that are that are
relevant to you and that you can
understand, for example in my
specific case now with Greek that I have
an advanced intermediate level let's say on
intermediate paper it would be said in English what
I do every day is  listening to a
podcast with a transcript and watching
videos with subtitles and that helps me a
lot 30-45 minutes a day and then he
talks once a week with my
wonderful teacher daria teacher
of greek and this is enough to
develop my language skills
and i have a great time i have a great time
and let's see here at the moment i speak
japanese english and spanish fluently what would
you recommend me to do to stay
fluent think create  content on
youtube is an efficient way
if you like it if you want to create videos on
youtube because you will not communicate with the
world you can receive what I think in
Spanish is feedback in English
feedback and why not I would say that
the most relevant is simply  to
maintain the languages and do things that you e
joy with the language is not neces
arily talking to others talki
g to when talking to natives or fr
ends who speak this language would be the b
st way to keep this language but y
u can also listen to the radio
you can listen to the  radio in this
language you can create write a diary
in this language do things you like
to keep them is  or is it the most
important thing if you like something you are going to
do it in the long term and that is what is the
criterion and the most important factor as
not only to save a language but to
develop it ok let's see here
santiago morales I am surprised how well
you  you speak spanish it seems as if you were
spain thank you very much santiago
telling me in spanish more or less more or
less but well spanish is very
similar to italian it's important
let's see here
daniel ferreyra i would like to learn
english he recommended a free website
and i'm from portugal  I think I'm from
Portugal but I also speak Spanish I would
use the link there is in it and in which
you
stop to sell to learn English
to learn there are a lot of languages
of languages that because they offer you k
vin offer please you can write the
you can leave a link and
well there is a sometimes you have to pay
for some things but in general you
can use it for free it's
amazing I like it a lot and  he has
lost Chinese with it is only with this link that he
has learned
learned Chinese
let's see here
[Music]
arsene hello teacher good important it
's strange to me when a teacher calls me
when wang how important is
linguistic talent when studying a
language talent pure work  pure that he
will win both things in the end I think
that the most important thing is clearly
work to
exist in class I always talk about steven
classes because because the guy the truth is
that the guy is a crack and he always says
that if he does those things well we
are all  in the middle of learning a language
very well then the talent sometimes
when we say talent this this payment
has talent has more talent than I
don't have it you put yourself in a category
you create the category of those who have
talent the category of what you don't have
no  he has talent and maybe you
put yourself in the second category, let's just say
it's not a good thing to start with I
think that in general the job is what
you do during the day  every day what you do
every day is what makes the difference
then of course there are people who have
more talent than others in some things
if I start running I want to run
like I don't know just in bolt it's clear that I
'm not going to run like usain bolt  it matters
very probably it is impossible but it will
run well if I run every day if
I want to do a marathon you can learn
to do a marathon anyone can and in the
end a language is like a marathon
so if you want to learn a language
what you have to do is
put on  every day having talent
in having talent it seems to me that it
plays a very minor role in
the learning picture the general picture
of language learning so
talent does exist we cannot deny it
but I think it is not the thing that is the factor
most important aspect of language learning
let's see
francisco martín luca how did you learn
dutch dutch and what level would you say
you have now bearing in mind
that it is not a language that  you use a lot I think
thank you and all my admiration
thank you very much francisco
I don't know it is difficult to answer this question
I would say p 2 more or less than 2 means
that I speak fluently I am always surprised
that even though I don't speak no the truth
is that I don't speak much  I speak from time to
time when I start to speak Dutch
it comes out and it comes out it comes out quite
easily clear sometimes I can't
think of words the other time for example I
replied to a student of mine he
is British but we sometimes send
messages the Dutch surprised me
because well they still come out quite
well I would say that it is because of the German thing
that helps me because I speak German
more often but I would say more or less a
b2
let's see here
when I have to sell
him to Khalil hello I'm from Azerbaijan
i learned spanish i
learned spanish on my own i want to
continue my studies in germany in
the future currently i have to
learn german but i have no motivation
and you recommend
good if you dont have mot  ivation I don't know if
you are going to learn a language, in general,
what I
recommend is to create, put yourself there for 30, 30
minutes and think
let's say imagine what is going to happen
in 5 years if you speak German
fluently you have to
emotionally connect with a language if you don't  there is
emotional connection nothing is going to happen
so you have to find a
way to connect with this language that
is through a book by a person
a trip maybe you will go to germany to the
movies whatever but you have to
find this way  Normally,
to connect with a language before I
learn it, I'm not going to do it with the
service. I've already done it. In fact,
I imagine I'll put myself there and imagine
how I'm going to speak, how I'm going to interact,
how I'm going to connect with Serbia with  the
Serbs with the people with the
experiences helped me a lot in this
sense the trips for example when I saw
the trip to Serbia
my memories the things that I have the
experiences all that helps me because it
pushes me  I know the difference it makes to
speak a language when you are in this
place when you are serving
me I have always been fascinated by Serbia and
the Balkans in general, the
Balkan countries I think it is said and that is why I
imagine what is going to happen in
I already believe the future I imagined my future only by
imagination Einstein said no that
imagination is the most powerful weapon
we have and I totally
agree with him
let's see here
let's see
Lucas in Portuguese well here you see it in
Spanish one  thing at a time before the one done
in English I hope that you
appreciate the fact that we are
doing it in Spanish I have a lot of
people who follow me who are
Spanish-speaking who speak Spanish so we
decided to do this
this life and well you see  that you have a
lot of very interesting questions
thank you very much for all the enthusiasm
for all those things that you do
but you want to one day
learn a regional language as in the
case of it  alianos el ombard piemontese
or something the truth is that no no now maybe it
will happen but no I don't have this this
wish
[Music]
let's see
iñigo a like I think it is said that it is read
like that for language they are similar to
Portuguese or  Italian would not be better for
a Hispanic is to spend a long time
listening to the language, learning to read and
write it,
understanding it perfectly, recognizing all
the sounds of both Portuguese and
Italian, and then when you have
internalized all that, it will start now
because I don't think that with languages  very
similar is all this type of
strategy let's say it can work
I would say why not
in this case it works in other cases with
slightly more complicated languages such as Russi
n German which is very different is Fi
nish or Finnish or I don't know
ussian Polish  that's much more
difficult but yes because you can't
do it without problems try it and let's
see what happens
let's see here
let's go to d
luís angel ramírez angel I think that  You've already
asked a question, I'll answer this
the second when you think you can
start learning a third language
I always have that thought of starting
a third language but sometimes I
get the idea that I need to learn
more in my second language whenever you want
if you think that you already speak your second
language fluently you feel comfortable
well then you can start the third
language that is what I would tell you we are going to
see a couple of questions here in the
little sheet that I have
we are going to see balance yes yes I would like to
ask you something now  I consider you to be a
true example of a polyglot, thanks
not only for the number of languages
eak but also for the level you reach in ea
h one of them. How is it that you track
your progress in perfe
ting your accent? The easie
t thing would be to get direct feedback.  but
how would the self-taught version
of this process be without someone to let you
know the subtleties the subtleties where
you still fail thank you never er  it's a
great thank you very much
I think I have already answered this
question as I have already said I identify
with the native speakers I want to
be like one of them I belong to my
tribe the tribe of Italy I am Italian
but I also have the
subconscious and conscious ability  of wanting to
belong to another human tribe and that
makes a huge difference more than anything other than
deliberate instructions and I don't
know work there you wear and read and that is
what makes the difference is what has
made the difference in each of the
languages  who spoke then identify yourself
with another tribe in quotes and then
practice and let's say when people
give you feedback or feedback
I have one let's say one my way of
accepting feedback also makes a
difference there are a lot of people who
say that corrections are not useful for
nothing I think that especially
with the pronunciation and the feedback that
the natives give you is very
important depends on who gives it to
you how they give it to you when they give it to you
etc etc etc but this is really useful
then talking to others is
important most of let's say the
fact that I develop more or less
let's say more or less an almost
native accent in  some of the languages I speak
depend on me and then clearly it also
epends on the corrections I recei
e but that is what I think plays a minor
role it is more my desire to ident
fy with the language and with its speak
rs you c
n learn two languages at the same time
I have talked about it a lot, it is
a question that they ask me all the time,
we have to bing, please, you can
put it there, you can put a link,
we have two or three articles and it seems to me
two videos on youtube or one where he
explained all the things you can do
to learn languages I would say yes you c
n if you have energy time if yo
want to invest energy time why n
t but a mistake that I think many
eople make is wanting  learn
two very similar languages and there you will get confu
ed they are diffe
ent they are different and distant languages always comedian be
ween them again if you want if
you want to save time and energy beca
se we are not goi
g to see here hello what
would like to know among all the lan
uages you speak  What are
e the three languages that you speak best and why h
ve you achieved them? Also pract
cal personal work reasons, thank
you very much. I wou
d say that apart from Italian, which is my mo
her tongue, it is English, Frenc
and Spanish in English because I hav
been using English for 30 years and
then I speak it, I write it, I have to write
articles, make videos, that is, English
is something, it is a language that I used all the
time, all the time, French because
I started school when I was about 10 years old,
in primary school, and then
I saw a lot of  a lot of movies
when he was like 14 between 14 and 15
let's say and then he had
a french girlfriend he
lived in france for three years
studying  go with my french ex-girlfriend for
5 years i
also attended a school of well
it's an interpretation and
translation school so i've lived i don't know a
quarter of my life in france and
through french and spanish because i lived in
barcelona and the truth is  that for
five months which is not a long period
of time
and I was wondering a school in
Catalan only everything was in Catalan but
apart from living in Spain I don't know I do
n't know what exactly has happened
with Spanish but I think that with
Spaniards are partially Italian, it is a
very similar culture, I identify a lot
with Spaniards in general, with
Spanish-speaking people, also in
South America, I like your way of
thinking, because this way of speaking,
your way of acting is very similar
to mine, that happens to me.  also with
Greek so I identify a lot with
this language and it comes naturally to me to speak I
don't know I don't know how to explain why exactly and
I've read a lot I've seen movies
I have friends
I've done a lot of things in Spanish
so those are the three languages that I think
I speak better then in Italian let's
see here another question later well then
e'll have to come back and it's already a quart
r past eight here so we have to finish unfor
unately I have to  I'm 30 I
still have 30 questions here and I don't know
how many questions I have in the chat I
think what we're going to do is if you
feel like it and if you want we can do it
again we can do a part number
two in a month maybe we'll go  let's
see and then these questions will stay
here so I'm going to answer I want to
answer everyone more or less
everyone so
well it's not but it's not a quarter past eight
so we still have 20 minutes or
more 30  minutes because we are going to
last an hour and ten minutes
so maybe we have a little more time I
was convinced that we had
started at seven we have started at
half past seven so let's see what
we have lost a leaf
that is the
chigüín and then I am going to say it at the end
again we are going to see here
how to learn Polish you can live there
next year in the next year
thank you very much I would start with something
called riel polis orioles which is a
last
I would do a combination I would use like this
thousand from one side to start and then I would
use riel policy there is also another
other resource for now I don't remember
what it is called later if you leave me a
comment in the comments session
it will leave you the three resources  the three
resources that i would use like this were you and
miku caputo ask me hello luca what
advice do you give me to start in russian with
desire well what i told
you before you have to connect with the
language first of all because you are
learning because you want to learn
russian maybe if you are not so motivated
and so lively you will go to russia
after 10 days and then if we have the language
and the people you will get with
russian and p  To start I would use
again I assimilate Russian which is a very good book
which way mar I think it is called
güímar so I have seen a couple of
comments this is good very
interesting these comments do you
agree with his they have a face without steve
kaufman about him  issue of buying
contingency is enough they say that
talking and paying attention to details
are not important I agree with
the part that comprehensible input is
essential to develop your
language skills there are things
about which I do not totally
agree and I think that  to speak to
speak well you have to have what
they call
feedback feedback in Spanish so
I don't agree that they say that you
put yourself there you listen and if you talk to
others and everything will turn out perfect that
's not true  in my experience
this is not true if you want depends on the
level you want to reach if you want to
speak video well more or less with
errors and  it's fine they're super good you
listen you watch movies and then
you speak with mistakes if you want to speak
well something else is something else and you have
to use what is called
deliberate practice I don't know if I have a
book here no it's not over there it's in
another room is called kick the
science of the express maybe
kevin or berta can
leave a link and it's one
of the best books I've read
about learning in general if you want to
reach very high levels very high level
high general in everything whatever
we are in chess play chess
sports learn languages and others to play
he violin you don't need to do what
s called deliberate practice and that is su
er important let's
see here have you thought about being an inter
ediary between people  who
like to teach and learn another language I
'm not sure I understand the question
until I think more about being an
intermediary between people who
like to teach and learn  understand the language
i am sure i understand louis
how to learn english from scratch and
reach a level at an intermediate level
fabricio i have already answered this
question we are going to add times temps so
you can listen to my answer to this
richard can you recommend books in russian
by  level a2 b1 to do reading and there is
a method called the frank method or
something like that
now now I don't know where it is I have
about ten of these books it's called the
frank method it's a language method
for interline bilingual books
it's called and by  please now
now now they don't come out
I can't think of a part of the name
called frank but if you write the
frank method in English frank method to
learn languages you will find it and there
are a lot of books for students on the u
e of  this level
please if you
can you can leave a comment in the
comment session but you can't remember
tell me never please I have this
question and I will look for the
link can  look for the books and then
I'll leave you a link
when you return to Japanese ernie asks me
and I know you leave a lot of
comments thank you very much for your
words your compliments always
if it's difficult Japanese is difficult I think
in 2023 23 I don't know let's see 24  now I
am going to start with Serbian I would like to
learn better to refine
Greek and Hungarian I will start Serbian
on January 3 and then I will return
to Chinese in Japanese because it is not left
over there and they are spectacular languages
going to give  here
louis hi my husband loves you send him
greetings please luca hi hi husband
luis if i put the frank method in
diary books of ana frank if it's good
then i'll go please you have to remind me
of the things i don't remember i
have the books  here but we don't have
time to look for them right now
realistic i saw it the other time
but now i don't i don't know where you are a
lot of books there
let's see here
jonathan i'm studying french  and it
is costing me more than Italian to
port of that even English above
all to find natives who put up with me
for exchange you have great advice
thank you very much I did not have enough
for French and in general if you want
if you want to practice the language I
would pay the  someone has services
like talk and ferb link they are platforms
where if it weren't for two bucks I don't know if
10 bucks 10 10 euros or 15 dollars or
less less than 15 dollars sometimes
you can find a tutor and pay the
three euros I've seen this then
well for very little money you can find a
tutor and I assure you that when you pay
someone they will appear while
asking is much more difficult
then if you have a little dough a
little money to invest that you can
invest I
would look for someone on those platforms and
once you have found someone
you like then you stay with him or her
for years that is what I am doing
with my Hungarian and Greek tutors
i'm having a great time
don't give your hi luca how many and how many
hours a day do you practice your study is the
language when you're a beginner
about an hour 11 a day
marco Cuevas o la boca how's your
plant-based diet going pretty well  but
i'm not this way the truth is that i've
gone back to eating meat a bit but very
little is going well it's going well i can't complain i
just bought another book by a
guy named greger who i advise you to
call sounds diet
as they don't make a  regimen in the sense
that it explains how instead of making a
legion of a regimen you can
eat healthy and this payment of this guy is
a crack that is the
hell greger is called greger we have already talked
about this with berta and maybe two days
ago  you can leave a link and haunted
there is an out gates they are both books and it
also has an incredible site
about food everything is in
english
luca because he didn't decide to learn arabic
because I have other languages to learn there
is  Who is there, you have Aragón Arabic
in Italy, so this language is wonderful,
past person,
I just have an order, I can't, I would like to
learn all the languages in the world, I don
t have, I don't, I don't lack time, I don't
have all the time in the world to learn
all their  languages then me now w
th serbian later later i don't
know there is turkish arabic arabic and let's see what
ther languages it depends on him life circum
tances are going to happen hello lucas
how would i start to learn a slavic lang
age taking there are a
lot of questions about how to start gloss matte
and I think that
a language will start is to take let's say a resource a
good resource to start and then
you put yourself there and then once you
have a solid base as I said
before you can use other resources I
advise you to simile for the use no  I know what
Slavic language you want to learn but there is a
simile it produces spectacular courses
especially for
state languages for Asian languages it is a little less  s
but for slavic languages and in general europ
an languages fabricio silva is very good how to lear
them my most freque
t words in english simply by l
stening and reading things that intere
t you if they are more frequent you will co
e across them all the time later how m
ch do you think i should study for
being able to reach an intermediate level
of English and how long a day you
should study to reach it depends
on how long you want to take it depends on whether you
normally need one year two years
at least to learn a language
fluently what I define fluency
then I would say  an hour a day
every day the most important thing is the
frequency if you study 30 minutes or an
hour doing things you like with
input such as books or
comprehensible materials that you can listen to and read
comprehensible interesting you are going to
learn whatever language it is in a  a year or
two it doesn't matter if a couple of questions
here
how many languages do you have left to learn until
when will you say no more  with these
that he has learned enough as
he started
the video saying that I am
immensely curious and then I am never going to stop
learning I don't know I don't think I am going to
stop learning languages until you are 80 years
old let's see if I am going to be in
this land on this planet for 80
years languages are used in the head when
hey are similar or the brain they go to ea
ily naturally depen
s sometimes if it happens to me when I start another langu
ge that is similar a language that I alr
ady speak as I started to learn  Polish Rus
when I already spoke Russian fluently
when I started
Portuguese when I already spoke
Spanish fluently and in other cases it happens
for a while and then I get confused
sometimes but not much because I developed
a personality in these languages
tribe I was from  spea
before then the confusion
also comes from the use when you
use the language if you use one much
more than the other if let's say it is very
complex that I have spoken  I also talked about that
in an article and in a video
but in general they don't mix much
now it depends on the moment
there are also questions here to which I
already
answered very, very similar questions
so unfortunately I don't have to
because I can't read all the questions
because we  there are only 10 minutes left
let's see here
do you think one day you will leave
language learning in the background
to learn new skills because
stop learning languages in the steel I have
o replace it can I continue learn
ng languages and do something else like if I w
uld like to play the  guitar
I always say next year
next year I think that in 2023 it will
be the year of the guitar and of other
languages
s the best experience you have had u
ing this language Spanish a lot n
no no no  I can name one there is
only one there are a lot
there are many to live in Barcelona
there are many no no there is not one in
particular
there are many is the sum of the
experiences that make a difference
you know
and we are going to see how to learn the language
by itself what is the best way if
you have some basic beige tips such
as for example to start learning
the verbs or something similar we have already
talked about these many times in
this  live I would say just don't
start with the verbs you start
listening and reading again things
that interest you you are going to learn the
verbs as a consequence I don't have a
focus on the verbs the articles the
two colors you have to
focus on learning listening reading reading
and  listening to things content that you like
and that is understandable all the rest is going to
be a consequence
how could the German be improved if it has been
stuck at an intermediate level
for a while I feel that nothing is progressing
thank you very much
you can see there are three videos on youtube
that  I've done about about this in
particular they all have
english subtitles and the and if you have a
google extension that is  call google chrome
sorry they are called line witcher and hector
you can also see them in spanish I
advise you to see them if you write how to
go from b1 b2 c1 you are going to see leave a
lot of
details let's say the information the
problem is that now we don't have time
to answer this  question because
it takes two hours to
explain what to do
we are going to read a couple of other questions
here a couple of the chat
we are going to do here you can learn
german by reading and listening without
having to do anki files I ask
because I still feel very effective anc and I know
it makes me tedious because of the time because
every day there are more and more cards an advice
that I always give to those who
have experienced burnout not
when when you are up to your nose
you are overwhelmed with these with these
cards see those cards I don't know if they are
cards  or cards in Spanish from here is
simply I check with my notebook two
minutes a day and then I always hear
things that I already and
about  I have already worked with them before, for
example, if I listen to a new podcast,
I use a transcript to
understand it because it helps me to see the
words that I am listening to and then
the week the following week he begins to
listen to things that he has already understood and I
revise this way because he is
revising words
listening you are spending time with the
language you are listening to the language and you don't
get overwhelmed I about the pnc and I never
used it I will never use it I don't like it
very much meet people that we say I like
but it got a little overwhelmed this is what
that is what
What language do you think is easier
for a French or Spanish speaker?
I would say that Spanish is much
easier than French, above all
in terms of pronunciation, the languages are very
imilar to each other, but I would say that Frenc
is more  difficult because of the
pronunciation it is difficult for an
Italian and for a Spanish-speaker or
Spanish-speaker to pronounce
French well because it has, for example, the
regular like ok yes it is difficult
to pronounce which is your favorite book
tell me here a favorite book in each
language because well a couple of a couple of
things that I wrote down beforehand
just let's see if I can read my
writing they
are
in  spanish i don't know what it's called
maybe narcissus and mouth of gold i don't know is it
all in italian is it narcissus summoner or
do i have it in spanish the german italians
or books by hermann hesse and it's one of
the books he marked the most when
he was 13 years old  in love with this book
a book one of the most
important books in world literature you
we need to work the day drop is
amazing gift word of the rings
the lord of the rings' I think it is
said in Spanish of tolkien and of  stephen
king that a book that has marked a
lot that we have out there in
all languages they still do not stop believing you i have talke
about that incre
ible food tania de test and pizzi folk in engli
h the rampant baron in italian italo
calv  ino is my favorite italian writer
I have to let's see here alfonso falcón
is the cathedral of the sea' of the shadow
shadow and the shadow of the wind I think of
carlos ruiz zafón the seagull and I
remember the song of the seagull of
sepulveda and many others
I have a  a lot I could speak a few
sentences from the books because I read
at least three or four books at the same
time and every day for a couple of
hours I'm like I'm a little crazy with
this how do you maintain your Spanish well
we've already spoken we've talked about that and  don't
forget pic marco tell me you can
leave a comment later if you leave a
comment in the comments session let
's say later there may be in
the comments tomorrow because after
this it's a bit tiring and I'm going to
reply to everyone
berta I have  seen that he has left a daffodil
and goltz world novel of the germ that to
edit is no longer daffodil and summoner
nobody is a colt
you go what else we still have five
minutes and I have a couple of questions from
facebook and instagram
bárcena but macherano i know how
to pronounce trinity hello lucas thanks
for your videos the question is what do
you think learning the different accents
in a language makes sense is it possible to
change the accents depending on the
person with whom you speak my example is
they give me accents quite well and that
never interested me until the moment
when I started to have this interest
in Portuguese from Portugal although he speaks
with a Brazilian accent and I want to save it
too but I would like to be able to speak
with other accents I'm crazy
thank you very much no no no no  you're crazy if
you want to learn to speak with both
accents you can but it's a lot of work I
know and it won't be very easy because when
you identify with one accent it's hard to
change the other I can't imagine
speaking I can maybe imitate a little
Argentines who are a bit like
Italians but the truth is that it is very
difficult for me to speak Spanish with a
Mexican Colombian accent  or because I
identify with a Spanish accent and in me
and in my mind my identity is
in castizo Spanish I don't know what about Spain'
that's why he changes and the same with him for
all this Portugal I speak Portuguese
Lusitano they call it Porto from Portugal
difficult to change  Now
you can speak Brazilian Portuguese if you want, of
course, but you have to get involved and it's not going to
be easy.
How would you recommend starting to learn a
difficult language like Chinese without triggering the
speaker? That is, the steps that
should be followed, what resources could
always be used the same  so thousand link
and mandarin corner those are the three
civilians anis towards the chinese link which
is amazing with the chinese mandarin corner
which is a fantastic youtube channel
for beginners and above all
intermediates
fernando says lucas of the searched
avoid argentinian please next time
time
we are going to see
after time that allows to rest
russo diet primates and size we are going to see
here what is your advice to achieve
fluency in an e  xforeigner that helps you to
pass to level b2 and c1 and c2 if this question has not been
answered with the times
temps you will be in the middle of seeing
exactly where my answer is and
the last two questions what is the
best way to keep the
spanish separated  from Italian when I learned
Italian when I learned Italian from
Spanish I'm not sure what you
mean by this the truth if you want to
have the two languages separated you have to de
elop my identity our langu
ges and speak it every day with people
you want to talk and spend time
ith  this is not well understood
your question
and the last question on facebook and
then I am going to answer a couple of
questions here and then
unfortunately we have to close the truth is
that I will stay here all day
because the Russian Slavs Polish Czechs
because the Russian Slavs  Czech Poles
seem to have an easier time
learning other languages, this may have to
do with the fact that their respective languages
they have declension that endings in
contrast in our Latin languages
ost in the use of Latin cases and t
ey are prepositional we use prepo
itions and this is a comment by rique
and it is very very long so he is not going to re
d it all due to lack of time I would
simply say that  sometimes they have a
diary, let's say a phonetic inventory, that
is, more sounds in their languages and their langu
ges are objectively
more complex let's say I wouldn't sa
more complex but they have a cert
in grammatical
complexity and when learning languages l
ke Spanish Italian it is easier for the
there are a lot of
Romanians who speak Spanish perfectly well
I ran into one with a human girl who
spoke Spanish too which I didn't know
was incredible I was stunned
this is what I would say I would say yes for
Latinos especially Italians Japanese and
Spanish let's say there are  certain poverty
of sounds for example the vowels
we have
ocu and dictated mushrooms and all that but the
The truth is that we don't have things like in
English there I don't know 23-25
ent sounds just for the vowels Engli
h seems easy but the truth is that
t is one of the most difficult in the world
to speak well because of the phone
ics that it is  something very very very
complicated well let's say that
we have finished there are two minutes left
then thank
you carolina fabián 97 do you think it is a strategy to
learn a language with the translator
translate the sentences that one uses
on a day to day basis and from these
learn the grammar it is not there it is not there
wrong or use the translator there are two types
of translators that we can use
google google translate is well
known later in types of pl which
is also very good for translating
use I use it above all to have
conversations with tutors I prepare
beforehand and I prepare sentences  and phrases and
words that you will use during a
meaningful conversation talking about
what i like
about richard frank's is not alone the
russian e book  n Russian I really think so
I think it has been developed
for this in me but in me on my site
there is also a reference to another system
of interlining books it is called that it is
very good that we can that you can use
it is called interlining box
and it  you have me on my page in never
lampariello is in some articles
now I don't know if maybe you can
get this but we have a
reference to this site that is a friend of
mine and we also have a filet link
and these books are amazing because
they are in both languages in various combi
ations so especially in Engli
h he is Greek and he is Russian Japanese Japan
se and English so it is incredible I thi
k we have finished and I would like,
as you have already said, that he stays here all night
but it is not possible  and
for all those who for
whom we say the questions I have not
answered your questions I
am sorry because it is very complicated to do
all this in just one hour but again
we are going to do  if you liked it you have
found this live well
let's say useful for you
we can do another one in a month
maybe I don't know if at the end of December
I have to I don't know I would like to be on
vacation because I don't take vacations
this year it has been a bit  complicated but
we are going to do others especially in 2020
22 so we will have more
opportunities to chat
thank you you are wonderful
and I would say that we are done
thank you very much to everyone for sharing
experiences for asking questions for
sharing your enthusiasm because in the
end speaking languages is  a question of
enthusiasm is a question of
communicating with the subjects that you want to
do other things intellectual
curiosity emotional curiosity emotions that is
what counts in life is if you want to
learn another language and if you are going to learn
another language it will change your life
it is going to give more lives in one let's say it is to
live how to live several parallel lives
in one
thank you very much for everything they
are wonderful  as and wonderful and
see you next time here on youtube
thank you very much and have a very good
day
bye